[Music]
from baslerman
the director who reimagined shakespeare
reinvented the musical
and redefined a classic
comes a bold new vision of an american
icon
but this ain't no nostalgia show
we're gonna do something different
comic book heroes all find their super
powers
elvis found music uh bring that bass up
jerry i wish to promote you mr presley i
believe i can be great
some people wanted to put me in jail as
well's moving don't so much just wiggle
a finger
[Music]
[Applause]
in that moment elvis the man
was sacrificed
and elvis the god was born
[Music]
i would do anything to make sure my mom
and daddy never had to live in poverty
ever again
[Music]
colonel you put an end to your boy's
animal behavior or we will
there's a lot of people saying a lot of
things
but in the end you got to listen to
yourself
you let me dry and you still want
[Music]
are you ready to fly i'm ready to fly
elvis reading pg-13 friday
[Music]
there's the maniac who seeks to end us
all
and putting together the greatest team
ever are you packed
yes
we've got
he's my best friend
there's my ex-girlfriend jane
valkyrie
[Music]
they also scream quite a lot
you said this would be a relaxing
holiday
i said it was going to be like a
relaxing holiday
human handshake
to the asgardian shake
into the snake
that you cannot trust
really dragging this out and finish the
classic asgardian high one
in theaters july 8 tickets on sale now
oh you've got to be kidding me
yeah
this is 476 barbary right yeah i'm
renting this place no i booked it a
month ago are you sure you have the
right place yeah who am i supposed to do
why don't you come inside and we'll call
these idiots
[Music]
why don't you just crash here oh no
i don't know if you've got a great look
at this neighborhood
but i don't think you should be out
there by yourself
it's dry and there's a lock on the door
by the way i'm keith tess
you take the bedroom and i'll sleep out
here on the couch
oh god
[Music]
keith
keith
this process might seem overwhelming
but with a little practice
it can soon become
a pleasurable experience
this is perfectly natural
[Music]
life there was like a frozen river
[Music]
the surface was beautiful
but underneath
it's a joyless and a lonely life
but you
you are different
[Applause]
that's where
you can change everything
[Music]
i know i'm not an ordinary 10 year old
kid
then again
no one's ordinary
cookie can't change the way he looks
so maybe we can change the way we see
[Music]
tell me about this new school of yours
right now i'm just trying to fit in it's
kind of been my mother ever since i left
my old school julia you did not leave
your old school you're expelled
for being cruel to another boy
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm sure your father has told you
stories about when i was a young girl
he says you don't really like to talk
about it i don't but now i think for
your sake
i must
excuse me
oh god what is he doing i saw this on
your desk thanks you're welcome i didn't
even know his name
but we had in common one crucial thing
he's really good
for a jew
we had both seen
how much hate people are capable of
and how much courage it took to be kind
find out
you need to come with me right now i
know i am
in dark times small things remind us of
our humanity
how'd you like to visit new york tonight
sure
open your
the eyes of reality has its limits the
world of imagination
is boundless
you're the bravest person i've ever met
you forget many things in life
but you never forget kindness
like
love it stays with you forever
i am pushing boots
you want to see something cool
gracias the legend will never die
you died i have nine lives and how many
times have you died already uh
no persian bull doesn't need a spotter
watch
watch
a cat always lands on his feet watch
you are down to your last life mama luna
is always on the lookout for a new lap
cat i have no lab cat i am possible
[Music]
this is a person potty pickles that's
your party so this is where dignity goes
to die
you don't look like a pickles well
you don't look like a cat
full disclosure i'm a therapy doctor why
were my belly
hard buzz
they found me
goldilocks and the three bears crying
make her
talk excuse me my darling we're looking
for the legendary [ __ ] boots have you
perhaps
seen him
what a puss in boots
he
is me
oh
[Applause]
normally i have a sword it's like a
whole thing okay
get that cat dead or alive will be just
right bounty hunters kitties
i need your help whenever i team up with
you things go wrong cool another member
of the team i'm pussy's therapy dog
definitely not finally you need therapy
oh i have got to learn how to do that
lives flashing before your eyes pray for
mercy from persian birds
[Music]
i don't trust you trust me
you gotta trust him look at those eyes
you call that cute no
i'm with the paws am i doing it stop
you're gonna give yourself a harness
hey guys it's bobby lieber coming to you
from the future home of the lgbtq plus
museum everyone is really excited and
totally getting along
this happens to be my sexual awareness
week and no one has acknowledged it
lesbian history month was in march
nobody said a goddamn thing of course
lesbians get a month and we get a week
so what's happening didn't you guys have
an announcement this is a little
unexpected but we are in a throuple
situation you're in a trouble
me tell you what's progressive now being
alone i love my life i love my freedom i
love my independence that's kind of sad
that i don't want to be in a throuple i
don't even want to be in a couple
bobby i had sex with that 65 year old
jesus he's rich i don't know it's like
they injected steroids into dumbledore
oh my god that's aaron
he's very hot
gay guys are so stupid i know but we've
been smart enough to brand ourselves as
being smart it's our little secret
you met a guy i don't think i'm his type
he's a gay tom brady what are you into
one of these ripped idiots with no
opinion no i'd like someone who's
physically very frail and won't stop
talking and i bet he's as intimidated by
you as you are by him i'm down for
whatever yeah i can do whenever and i
can do whatever cool whatever one ever
gif of michael scott dancing office gif
this person isn't gay
i need you to be honest with me you like
these growing meat head idiots oh no
they're fighting do you like that i can
be tough like you're boys oh that's what
you like
what's going on
that's cool
happy pride happy pride now i have to go
to a pride party and you're both too old
to be in the pool
please leave
people are threatening to boycott the
museum you can't say lincoln was gay if
we don't do this we're letting the
heterosexual terrorists win there are
trans terrorists too caitlyn jenner
you're so different from me you're very
intense
i like to keep things chill i can be
chill just like a manly man what's up
what's up
what is going on with you my whole life
i prided myself on being self-reliant
but this guy has gone into my head
maybe you're both bottomed and that's
the problem
sex was more fun when straight people
were uncomfortable with it
oh my god do you guys remember straight
people yeah they had a nice run
[Music]
deer creek international business
solutions how can i help you i am ready
well that's great ladybug ladybug your
new operational name oh i see what
you're doing ladybug supposed to be
lucky
you don't have bad luck
really
my bad luck is biblical i'm not even
trying to kill people and someone dies i
remember the suicidal bell boy you drove
him to the hospital hang in there buddy
he didn't die okay the wedding
[Music]
johannesburg
it's time for some change you want it
simple for your first job back it
doesn't get simpler
[Music]
we need to find the person who took that
case
[Music]
that's too easy
[ __ ] what remember those two wackos from
the bolivia jobs the twins yeah and i'll
switch to their twins get off the train
[Music]
you stab me
what
i missed my stop something else going on
here hi
you don't remember me you look like
every white homeless man i've ever seen
really you don't remember me
oops he's a pack of dicks lady i'm sorry
i'm sorry i'm i'm working on it
get off at the next stop sounds so easy
when you say it one little prick from
this you know what happens yes your
blood congeals
i said
[ __ ] yes you're going to want to hear
the whole story that's waiting for you
the white death with his army of
assassins there's this soulless
psychotic leader with the largest
criminal organization on the planet
shoved right inside i don't see the
white death letting any of us off this
train
we need to come up with a plan
[Music]
what's happening to your face maybe
there was a little head trauma maybe
[Music]
i i gotta get off this train
[Music]
sorry buddy
exclusively in movie theaters warning
this film contains an unlikable female
protagonist viewer discretion advised
have you ever wanted to be noticed so
badly
might actually be the worst person we've
ever covered on the show acting like she
was the victim turned a lot of people
off to her i was just gonna bleach the
front bits but i'm really not trying to
get mistaken for danny sanders
this is so [ __ ] up isn't it kevin
white women
my name is danny sanders and on april
10th a string of terrorist attacks
struck paris i almost died
just kidding
be careful what you [ __ ] wish for
he's a crocodile he can sing
[Music]
music is a world within itself
with a language we all understand
[Music]
there's a crocodile in the house oh
hello you must be the new tenants i took
p valencia at your service i said you've
met my crocodile he's an extraordinary
talent his name is
mom i swear to you he's not dangerous
he's a crocodile okay yes crocodiles can
fight through boning yes they have a
taste for human flesh but he's not like
that he wears a scarf
and he can sing
[Music]
are you sure this is safe who wants to
say we're here to live and living as a
dangerous person
that was awesome there is
[Music]
it's his first time in a taxi
[Music]
what is it you like to talk about
my patient
hi
i know you're nervous i just want to
have a chat
i'm seeing something no one else can see
except for me
that's smiling at me
[Music]
yesterday a patient in your care died
brutally in front of you
[Music]
i need to find an explanation for what
happened
it's smiling at me
just smiling at me
[Music]
[Music]
i found 20 cases involving 19 victims
with a direct line linking them all
together
[Applause]
you said only 19.
why is it that everybody else who's seen
it is dead in your life
i've seen it too
[Music]
how long between each victim's death
none of them survived longer than a week
today's my fourth day
i am not gonna keep running
i have to face it
how does it make you feel
[Music]
i'm just really scared that something
bad is going to happen
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to seabrook
humans zombies and werewolves have
learned to live together
sea brook is a part of our pack forever
every morning we are going to be
together
[Music]
we have a problem
last time outsiders swooped in the
seabrook our moonstone was stolen
they're probably here to clone me
to create an unstoppable cheer force me
why are they really here
these angry beings may not give us their
planet
no outsiders mess with our turf
we need to find their most precious
thing
our pack won't go down without a fight
they're here to take what's ours
so how does it make you feel
you can sense the waves
you know how strong they are
like swimming in rough surf
you feel they could crush you
or take you under
you just have to let it take hold of you
[Music]
[Music]
what if i told you
that today
you'll leave here
different
i'm talking
to you
bro what'd you see someone above the
clouds that's big i'll be big
you think whatever kill pops is out
there
[Music]
right here
you
are gonna witness
an absolute spectacle
[Music]
so what happens next
are you ready
are you ready
[Music]
here we go
i'm talking rich and famous for life
there's plenty of videos for flying [ __ ]
online nobody gonna get what we gonna
get what we gonna get the money shot
what's up undeniable proof of aliens on
camera
the oprah shot
you guys gonna tell me what's going on
hell no
it's aliens
they're just waiting for the perfect
time to shove metal probes up our asses
i'll be rooting for you
i think we pissed them off yeah they
repainted your house
they gonna come back
you ready
we got some work to do
nope i'll get him out
and i'll get the shot let's go baby
let's
go i need y'all to tell me what did you
see in a cloud
well it's not what you think
they took me
they took them all
i gotta get out
my brother is out there
i don't think they thank you
if you don't look at it
let's dream you're chasing
you end up at the top of the mountain
it's the one you never wake up from
you'll be getting a call from my
supervisor asking how my service was
five stars angel five stars
why do you want to hunt
because you all think that i can't
i saw a sign in the sky
i'm ready
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
there's something out there i'm talking
about
you can't i'm trying to protect you
protect me from what
it's time
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
[Applause]
[Music]
it knows how to hunt
i know how to survive
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
whatever did this
[Applause]
he thinks he can fight like his granddad
no god get you going
the only way to protect yourself is to
fight
[Music]
you ain't got it in him to do what you
did
give him time
he's just going to be our prize right
here
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen one damn belcher
you'll be a stronger
more experienced fighter just using your
hogging
fighting provides a snap ladder for a
pauper to become a prince
is this your first exposure to high
society it is
[Music]
leave
now you're gonna ask yourself
do you really want this
the championship prize fight was
being talked about across the whole
country
you're our prophet
one fight
you could be champion of england
[Music]
sorry i didn't wake you you look so cozy
sleeping through one of your fantasy
beatings
wanna go to a silent disco tonight i
have practice do you ever stop gaming
only to eat and sleep
it wasn't long ago big video games were
marketed entirely to a generation of
guys
[Applause]
but now gamers are everyone one two
three beta the you run support don't
screw it up
dustin they're flanking us
online okay seriously i'm a nationally
ranked player the only reason he was
spot on this team is because you guys
have you know vaginas i'm done watch
what i do we're gonna start an all girls
team and take down the babies
coach us come on mom they need you i
mean
they're totally pathetic hey
we need to get back to the basics oh my
gosh
[Music]
we're gonna try mentally lily look out
spiritually
we do this every saturday physically
will be only funding one esports which
means it's either you or the betas what
about my scholarship unless you win i
would be forced to cancel that girl
power everybody oh man
we're like [ __ ]
oh i'm ruben right now jump in baby
water's warm and i'm already wearing a
t-shirt what is happening
it's time to reignite the fire inside of
you like you're a kid again
[Music]
you never go full chicken lily
[Music]
like secrets
[Music]
okay
this is it everyone
we're here
to have some fun trapping baby no storm
troopers no tie fighters no threat of
annihilation
best vacation ever
summer's about to end and we're all
about to go our separate ways it's a
vacation relax hello there who are you
obi-wan kenobi
what is in this come on out in the sun
come on out and have fun we are on
holiday it's not that kind of holiday
one never knows how long a moment will
last you must learn to enjoy yourself
what do you know about vacations
the trip isn't about the destination
it's about the journey
go go go go
[Music]
who's next try not to lose a hand it's
kind of a thing in our family
[Music]
it's a
it's a i'm not saying it it's a snack
[Music]
black adam
what have your powers ever given to you
nothing but heartache
i was a slave until i died
then i was reborn a god
my son sacrificed his life to save me
now
i kneel before no one
going outside
in this world
they're heroes
i feel the pain in my city wherever i go
and their villains
heroes don't kill people
well i do
my vision has shown meet the future
you have two choices
you can be the destroyer of this world
or you can be its savior
that's up to you
behind you
did he just catch a rocket
you know my fresh coat
you can pay me whatever you can now you
are a good guy
but he needs the income i'm doing a
re-pipe up at tim whitner's place at
least we know he's good for it
[Music]
where is it
[Music]
how are we gonna find the money now
don't worry about it
[Music]
get him
we're in the house the middle of nowhere
we got nothing but time who are you just
a plumber bad luck for you then plumber
you got something down there that
belongs to us
[Music]
last kid plumber
can still make us a deal
here's the deal
you're not getting the money
you get nothing i hope it was worth it
there's nowhere
uh i'm to
plumber i deal with pieces of [ __ ] all
day long
[Music]
summer
a time for romantic fireworks
delicious hot dogs and watercraft
recreation is about to get way
more
lit
with some sweet summer jams
[Music]
oh
[Music]
presents a mickey summer spectacular oh
yeah too hot for cable tv
[Music]
oh
the wonderful summer of mickey mouse
streaming july 8th only on disney plus
[Music]
you